now please don't leave me here bro tell  us you're retired it's not safe for you  to be on your own I mean you're gonna  use I'll come visit maybe dirt bye bye  week  that's not tow week nine brothers never  visit so it's pretty neat here you can  help the retired Cowboys call bingo  games okay so based on this formation  I'm guessing the next ball will be n 24  what he said hey whit oh it's Marty when  I moved into the retirement home crime  dropped 100 percent here we see our  exercise programs my in season records  25,000 but I think I can beat that now  I'm sure Canada will call soon - yo I  still think they can play this place  sucks  I gotta get the [ __ ] out of here  Martellus you're 31 there's nothing out  there for you anymore I survived a 28 to  3 deficit I'm not going out like this  honey I be help cigarette  there we go miss communicating again  retired athletes have no love